yonders this is shag first i want to say
sink
karyatheria ima periphonias yosenya
congratulations uh how does it feel
you got it confused did you understand
my greek brother
no yeah uh i did a little bit
the first part of it okay hold on cinco
carloteria ima periphonos yesenia
is that correct he said congratulations
but i i don't even say that you think
you know
one word you got right that's your
question all right anyway
how does it feel coming from where you
come from to greece to you know have all
these honors to be one of the top
players in the game i could tell that
you're happy and you're emotional about
this war but
i know this look you have to look in
your eye that that this award is good
but this is not the ultimate award
so you know how does it feel coming from
where you come from
all right it feels great uh when i when
i got to the league i was 18 years old
you know people believed in me i
believed in myself and i know the only
way to achieve
a word like this is work hard each day
you know when you put your mind into
something usually comes true and uh when
you you know you
your action lead towards that usually
comes uh
to reality uh but at the end of the day
we gotta keep you know working hard
uh as a team um so we can as you say we
can get the big trophy
but you know it takes day by day as long
as we together as long as we play hard
as long as we go out there have fun
compete
good things gonna happen for this team